me
いいオレ
ねっ
こんにちははじめしゃちょーね皆さんクリスマスいるいかがお過ごしでしょ
どこで行動青木理スマートがやってきたんですけども
皆さんイルミネーションみましたかやっぱりをクリスマスと言うと綺麗な弓ネーション
見に行くみたいなた彼が好一般的にあるんですけども外は寒い出たくなかっプル
だらけるぜというわけで船の中で何とか準備ネーションを作れないかと考えたんです
けども
膣内でリミネーションってどう外何のキラキラネーム見えねーしょんや
踊っちゃうんで関係ない
いやー外には勝てないああ
だが私は勝ちますよまげでらんねーめちゃくちゃ指でしょッ買ってきました10名と
10名と10m メイトが10名と5m 10m ルームメイトルームメイト
ルームメイトフィメートル10メートル2メートルメートル10名が全部で50
メートル200メートル分の異名書を準備しました
パッああ
メデューサ200メートル分の弓フェスを準備しました
はぁ
ていた
外に出てます神実習寂しいなんか悲しくなるんで部屋の中でどころかな
イリミネーションよりももっと綺麗なイルミネーションこの部屋で奏でられないかも
たらで実際にやってみると思いますでは行こう
一人で行こうよん
では早速やっていこうと思いますコンセントの量がすごくなると思ったので詐欺作さあ
電源タップを買ってきましたペンギン早速増えても何度も対応できるようなしており
ますやこれすごいぞ室内では史上最強レベルにイルミネーションを作るんだね買って
からちょっと本当に頑張りますそれなりに消えますとこれはペアさせるつないでいこう
と思います
これすごい生瀬町永井ダキッ
[音楽]
1個ちょっとつけてみます
はぁっんっはぁっあったってうおおおおって以上でクリスマスさ
山自力でできたして守ろうやばいやばい楽しい
はい1まぁまぁまぁちょっと期から戦の最後のを楽しみにしましょう
[音楽]
うっをえええ
me
たぶん今ぐらいの行が一番綺麗だと思うんですよ次回つけていますか
いきますはい
[音楽]
もう
あれなんか普通の激しいなあああ
いかがでしょうかきっと今ぐらいでイルミネーションが一番綺麗だと思うんですけども
まだ半分も終わってませんからここからちょっともきれいを超えていくのかなっていう
気がするんですけどもまざまがあるのでちょっとどんどんつけていこうと思いますでは
[音楽]
思い出ばいつも綺麗だけどそれだけじゃお腹がすく
d っっ
なんかこれアレなんじゃねーよなんか開けた時せこいなんで意味ネーションが絡まっ
てるんで1回振り回さないとダメですよ
ハァハァなんでこんなからも済んだなはぁっ
[音楽]
はいという完成しました水がで結構購入したんでまぁだいたい300メートルでとかな
胆略メートル分のイルミネーションをここにすべて
晴れ作ってみましたはいとやっているとりあえず行って点滅させてみましょうでは次て
いきます
て
わー
今度はい待って待って待ってます明るい赤でやがれやばい超綺麗ですめちゃくちゃ変だ
から撮り水路が幻想的なんですよねー完全にクリスマスですねやめっちゃ綺麗だなあ
ああはいというわけで部屋がきれいになったら分かったと思うんですけどもうここで私
はー
思っイルミネーションて一つ目一つ目がとてもきれいなが強いようでちょっと弱そうな
光今めちゃくちゃたくさんのイルミネーション300メートル近くあるんですけどもう
このイリミネーションをすべて
と方針の束にするとどんだけ開かなくて美しいものになるのか想像ってすぞああっ
どうぞですね経済なると思うんですよ一例を一つにまとめると高めちゃ
セキレイな魂ができると思うのねあのせっかく壁に貼ったんですけどまぁから全部外し
てちょっと方がインドたまにしてめちゃくちゃ綺麗なイルミネーションボールを作って
みようと思います
めんどくさい
あつまれ led だっちゃ
今ことづけの一つにはい
できましたーーー
では早速史上最強のイルミネーションライトの光のするぞ
見ていこうと思いますせーなー0
メリークリスいます3
普通わーん
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ
わー
綺麗だけど
寂しいなぁたぶんあれだでもこれ電源を通した時の話したら瀬木やつを超すみます
うわぁ
な基礎